تتنافر صوره اخبار من حين الاخر عن فنان
كبير لا يجد مسكنا بعدما تقدم به العمر او
فنان يعيش وحيدا
من هنا كانت فكره دار للمسنين للفنانين
والفنانات او بمعنى ادق الحلم الذي راود
الكثيرين وطلبوا به عده مرات
[موسيقى]
واخيرا تحقق هذا الطموح بافتتاح دار القوه
النعمه اول دار للمسنين الفنانين من اعضاء
نقابه المهن التمثيليه بتبرع من سمو الشيخ
سلطان القاسمي حاكم الشارقه
قدره تستوعب 40 نزيلا من الفنانين ويوجد
ايضا عياده للرعايه الصحيه مكتبه وقع
للجنز
هذا المشروع يضمن للفنانين الذين اسروا
الشاشه والمسرح لسنوات طويله ان يعيش حياه
كريمه وامنه بعدما تقدم بهم العمر
[موسيقى]
الاضواء تظل اعمالهم قائمه والتي شكلت قوه
مصر الناعمه على مدار اكثر من قرن سمر
باشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره
[موسيقى]